Remember that x squared. It's just x times x or 2 x's multiplied together. X to
the 4th is just 4 x's multiplied together and we're also multiplying that by
another 3 x's that are multiplied together. So here we have a big string of x's
all multiplied together, just like we would expect, considering how many
exponents we see here, but the same base of over and over again. So, in total
here we have 9 x's all multiplied together. And we know that this just equals x
to the 9th power. However, we can or rule to do this in a much shorter and
easier way. We can get the same answer by just adding these 3 exponents
together. We know that our base is still x, but our power is just 2 plus 4 plus
3. 2 plus 4 is 6, plus 3 is 9. So we get the same answer.